hey guys we're here at CES unveiled now
you've seen a million different tablets
out there but this one's actually pretty
interesting idea it comes from the guys
from one laptop for child and they're
actually trying to get tablet devices
into the hands of underdeveloped
countries and kids around the world it
uh the cool thing about it is it
actually charges via kinetic energy or
solar power so if you do a hand crank
for about ten minutes it should get you
about six hours of battery life it's
supposed to be very cheaply made we
don't know the price yet but it should
be coming out sometime later this year
pretty durable it supports Android apps
it's got all the bells and whistles and
connectivity that you would imagine USB
microphone input and it's just an
all-around cool idea so in a market
where tons of people are producing
tablets this seems like the one
benevolent cause that I'd actually get
behind